okay for this week's classic interview
you might remember last week I pointed
to this economic indicator that we can
look at right now whereby a record
number of Americans are 90 days or more
behind on their car loans and we talked
about why the automobile but also the
automobile finance indicators are really
important if we want to try to figure
out what might be coming in the economy
this week's classic interview relates to
exactly that it's when I interviewed
Carole lock nut from the edmunds.com
Features section and so much of what we
discussed was exactly about this issue
how does car ownership and even beyond
that car culture figure in to the
economy let's get into that interview
from a few years ago right now I'm
joined today by Carole Lock knit
features editor for car shopping website
edmunds.com the topic today is quiet
vehicles vehicles that in some cases are
so quiet that it is becoming an issue of
safety
tell us how recently has this become an
issue and is it really an issue focused
around hybrid and electric vehicles it
really is an issue focused around hybrid
electric vehicles and pure electric
vehicles and it came to prominence I
think around 2008 2009 and the issue
really is that those cars because they
don't have conventional internal
combustion engines are very very quiet
at low speeds so these are speeds under
about I think it's about 18 miles an
hour so it became an issue initially
with the blind community the National
Federation of the blind race this is an
issue because it was concerned about its
members who rely obviously on some audio
cues for safety as they move around
cities I'm not getting those when it
comes to EVs and hybrid EVs and
typically the idea of a quiet car is
kind of considered a nice feature
generally or even a luxury feature in
higher-end but maybe not necessarily
hybrid or electric vehicles but we're
actually starting to see now
in fact there's going to be a law which
I'm sure you can tell us about which
will mandate that vehicles must make
noise right well I think the difference
here is that it's a luxury it's a luxury
aspect when you're inside the car right
so you want to be in a car that is quiet
and soothing if you like a luxury ride
and you feel a little bit cocooned from
the hurly-burly of the city around you
but cars even luxury cars on the outside
make noise their their engines make
noise so the issue be can really came to
prominence when there was a conversion
from a traditional internal combustion
engine to essentially an electric
generator which is at low speeds very
very quiet and when we look at the
actual number of fatalities and
incidents of pedestrians being hit by
vehicles is there a significant increase
that we can see over recent years
yes Nyssa did some studies around this
and we're not talking about fatalities
thankfully because these tend to be
low-speed incidents they tend to be
things that happen when a vehicle is
backing out when a vehicle is making a
turn when a vehicle is in a parking lot
although they have trouble isolating
that in terms of the study but the fact
is that when there is an accident that
accidents involving electric vehicles or
hybrid electric vehicles are 35 percent
higher for pedestrians and 57 percent
higher for cyclist bicyclists both of
those are huge issues here in New York
City where we are and I'm curious
whether some of the new so-called safety
features and I say so-called
not because I don't believe that that's
what they are because usually they're
under this umbrella like backup cameras
proximity sensors blind spot indicators
do those counteract in any sense the the
danger posed by the quiet vehicles or
are we really talking about two totally
separate lines of thought here I haven't
seen any in any of the research that
Nitsa did up to this point a
consideration of whether those would
help common sense would tell you it's
got to be helpful because particularly
in the case of backing up that's a
particular issue I
think for both pedestrians and cyclists
and and the motorists because you do
have sort of inhibited vision I would
think that backup cameras any kind of
alert system some of the blind spot
warning systems also have rear collision
warnings have to be helpful to sort of
give the driver of a hybrid or Eevee a
heads up that they are sort of in
stealth mode if you will and that the
pedestrian or cyclist is not aware of
them so it's got to be helpful in my
experience driving and I try to drive as
little as possible within New York City
but I Drive pretty frequently to leave
and come back from the city I find that
so much of what I see going on on the
road that is wrong in other words people
who clearly are they're going 30 miles
under the speed limit you drive by and
they're on a cell phone they're wildly
changing lanes signaling in the opposite
direction than the direction they're
going I'm sure you know all of the stuff
that that is that is so prevalent so
often I feel like no matter how much
attention I'm paying as the so-called
good driver good guy with a car I can
really only limit the risk posed to me
by other drivers to a certain extent and
that to a certain extent there are just
so many distracted and otherwise bad
guys with a car so to speak that I can't
really shield myself or cocoon myself
completely apply that to this issue of
quiet cars and pedestrians and is there
as the driver can't what can you be
doing can you truly protect yourself
from a pedestrian who may be crossing
the street where there is no crosswalk
but also from the point of view of the
pedestrian can you be completely
inoculated from the possibility of a car
hitting you simply by following the
rules I think clearly the answer is no
clearly the answer is no I think for all
of us whether we're and and probably
like you I on any given day may be a
pedestrian or maybe a bicyclist a driver
you have to be super alert and assume I
think which I'm sorry to say this assume
that other people are going to be stupid
because that's so often is what
happening pedestrians you know are not
angels all the time people are glued to
their smartphones if they're not plugged
into headphones they may well be looking
down at the screen and texting or
writing or doing any number of tests
while they're walking which I find
extremely irritating as a driver as
another pedestrian as a bicyclist
bicyclist said I know how it is in New
York but I in my community bicyclists
ride on sidewalks they ride they ride on
the wrong side of the street they do all
kinds of things that make them very very
difficult to cope with as a motorist
motorists do exactly in California they
do exactly what you're describing is
they're on their cell phones despite the
fact here in California it's against the
law to do that and they're completely
distracted so you know I think that in
this society all of us try to ameliorate
the dangers posed to us and sometimes
you do through laws and regulations so
sometimes you just try to do through
common sense but you know it's we just
have to have our heads up and our
attention focused all the time last
thing I want to touch on since we have a
couple of minutes we didn't you touched
on this briefly and I'm curious what
your thought is as someone who is at an
organization like Edmonds texting while
driving is there anything that can be
done to actually get people to stop
doing it because we see more and more
campaigns advocacy campaigns billboards
commercials etc etc and I see texting
while driving more than ever before it
is so often connected with that vehicle
that from a mile away you can tell
something is not right with the way the
vehicle is behaving I Drive by and the
person is looking down and texting is
anything effective at getting people not
to text and drive
that's such a good question and I think
based on your experience and I think I
haven't seen any data that says that
since the inception of X campaign we see
X reduction in texting I don't know what
it's gonna take I really don't you know
I've watched a very very moving short
film about the the carnage literally the
carnage in the wake of people texting
while driving and maybe it should be
mandatory viewing every time we get in
the car I don't know it's just so easy
and so tempting to text as you as you
know the the one of the the National
Safety Board's not nitsa but that the
Accident Investigation Agency the
federal one has called for a complete
and total ban on cellphones in cars
period and I think that that's sort of
extreme but that may be the only
solution to the problem of someone who's
who may literally be addicted to their
smartphone and unable to stop themselves
from texting it is incredible and it'll
be interesting to see as vehicle
technology continues to develop whether
there might be a technology solution to
the issue of texting while driving but
will continue obviously to follow it
we've been speaking with Carol Lok net
features editor for edmunds.com thanks
so much for being on with us today
thanks for having me David